it's an expensive place to be let me
tell you yes my incomes down 30% you
know they're just things I can't do
because I'm associated was saying
something too nice about his skill
that's when I first met you you weren't
even a trump supporter at the time you
were just sort of talking about the
techniques he was using and just because
of that everyone said oh Scott Adams
this mad guy he's far-right all of that
nonsense not that you were supporting
some of his policies necessarily but you
were just saying this is how he is doing
these things this is how he is gaining a
following and getting his message out
right so I identify as left of Bernie so
I still do now I still do because
socially you know I could give you some
examples but socially I do but what I
what I eventually saw in Trump is they
had a toolkit that I thought could just
do stuff other people wouldn't do take
on China
that's the toolkit you want be the best
cheerleader for the economy literally
get our psychology work in the right
direction hey everything's good
everything's good why don't you invest
okay it's the psychology of the economy
I thought nobody's going to do that as
well as him
and likewise North Korea I thought who
could who could have a meeting well
before it happened I was already written
about it I said who could have a meeting
with Kim jong-un and just turn this
personal maybe find a way in President
Trump so I'm a supporter in terms of his
toolkit but you know it doesn't mean I
agree with everything he does yeah
that's a hard place to be in though
right because people don't really care
for that second part of that say it's a
it's an expensive place to be let me
tell you yes my incomes down 30% you
know they're just things I can't do
because I'm associated with saying
something too nice about his skill can
you talk about that a little bit more
like what kind of business things have
dried up or even personal friends or I
don't want to say specifically where you
live but you do live in California I
mean you live in a place that is maybe
not so hospitable to some of these ideas
well let's just say there was a
rebuilding period where I had to make
new friends a lot of them you know
things of that building process are you
in right now well you know I'm living a
very good life with my girlfriend
Christina we're quite happy with what
the way things are so I don't have a
complaint there it's just an observation
as socially it became very difficult to
have the same friends what was that like
because I think everyone watching this
has been through that to some degree my
book is about that it's about what
happens as you start sort of coming out
of the political closet that you sort of
get thrown under the bus by people that
you thought were your friends next thing
you know there's this whole other crew
that's welcoming you it mean it really
is sort of a flip on everything you know
yeah only only my most let's say honest
friends were willing to say it to my
face and that only happened a few times
so mostly I just noticed that my
Facebook feed started to get a it was
getting emptier and emptier the I feel
like oh really only one picture was
posted all this week by all everybody I
know that's weird and then you see that
they've unfriended you and then you
check you know their feeds and you see
what their political leading is you put
two plus two together and here we are
yeah how does your background in
persuasion and magic and the cartoon and
everything sort of fit your your general
demeanor I said to you right before we
started that you're one of the few
people that I that I now know that when
I see them on Twitter I don't like them
less there are so many people that I
know that and what we all are not
necessarily on Twitter and online in
general but I see so many people that
like I kind of respect or I know and I'm
and then I look at their Twitter and I'm
like ooh
what is going on here and I'm sure
there's people that say that about me
too but you seem like you're pretty like
pretty much the same in both worlds but
to be fair there are a lot of people
look at my Twitter and say you're the
worst person in the world right I used
to like your comic but now I can never
laugh again yeah just in general I can
never laugh again well you get away
their ability not just to laugh at you
but the whole thing I have you noticed
that the humor has just completely
changed yeah yeah as has been said you
can't make a movie a funny movie a funny
TV show in fact if you watch like an old
Family Guy rerun the whole time I'm
sitting there thinking you couldn't make
that today I can do that
but humor has become reality and
politics and it's very entertaining and
thankfully we have the funniest
president we've ever had but so as a
satirist though what do you make of the
comedy side of this cuz you know it's
somebody like Seth MacFarlane who
created Family Guy you know they've said
I don't know that they're going through
with it but I remember a few months back
they had said this thing where they're
not gonna do any more gay jokes and it's
like well the show did you know 25 years
of gay jokes and now gays are equal so
this might be the time to make gay jokes
so you can you know further integrate
people into society that's what Don
Rickles did right it brought it out
together
or or The Simpsons you know they were
gonna take out up who for a while and
then Hank Azaria the greatest voiceover
actor of all time had to apologize for
doing an Indian accent man what do you
make them but not just the content but
the people behind it you know they've
been infected I'm generally okay with
the concept that society moves forward
and things that we used to laugh at we
didn't realize we're cruel and then
maybe you grow up and say oh that was
really mean er than it needed to be it
was it wasn't really trying to do that
so I'm okay with society evolving but
the trouble is it evolved away all the
things that were the normal joke
materials now it didn't affect me with
Dilbert because when you're in a family
newspaper there's yeah there's a cap on
what you can do so I was always well in
the family friendly version talking
about the workplace so it didn't affect
me much but has certainly changed the
landscape of humor probably forever yeah
do you feel freer because I think you
said to me last time you were here that
you you've got some fu money so that you
can kind of be free enough to to do what
you want yeah I mean I didn't think it
would be as expensive as it was you know
maybe I maybe I would have thought it
through but no I won't change my
lifestyle and I did recognize that I was
in this unique position where I had
something to say
that in my opinion was not biased yeah
it was just hey this is what I'm saying
there's a little good and there's a
little bad here so I thought it was a
unique niche niche niche yeah I'll go
with either one do you go with
I'll take either one I shouldn't say
words I never say I allowed I would have
said niche personally but I
except niche as I look at your lovely
decorations here I think that you were
probably right better to figure out the
critic the correct but it feels like it
fits somehow I don't know what do you
make are just sort of how as a guy that
you know you sort of came out of
newspapers as you said that now you use
all of this stuff in a different way you
know you sit in the morning do you do it
every morning you doing pretty pretty
much every morning right you get on
Twitter what do you have your phone just
like locked on something and you make
yourself some coffee and you just kind
of talk to the world that that's a big
transition from you know putting a
cartoon in the paper and letting it be
versus this fully interactive thing yeah
the difference is sorry yes I do coffee
with Scott Adams on the periscope app
every day and then it moves over to
YouTube but about an hour later on
replay but I started doing it because I
was just interested in the election and
there were people to talk to and I had
more to say and I didn't feel like
writing it all down all the time because
every day there would be three new
things to talk about and then it just
grew I wasn't I didn't really have any
expectation no plan
I wasn't planning to even monetize it it
just grew into a thing and now if I miss
a day because I do it on weekends two
holidays because people are so addicted
to having the simultaneous sip as I call
it so I I do a toast of coffee with with
the public and that they miss it and so
now it's sort of labor of love I would
really really miss it like this morning
my wife I wasn't working so well and I
was like I don't know if I could do it
but I got my hotspot working and then it
made me happy right like most most
watered down it from here we would have
let you know they've been great yeah
most work doesn't make you happy mm-hmm
you know you might like your job but
doesn't make you happy
whereas doing the periscopes it's just a
joy everyday yeah I actually did it one
morning I did coffee with Dave and I did
fully credit you with the coffee idea no
one was talking with coffee before you
but I did think that there was something
nice about just starting the day just
sort of unloading a couple of thoughts
just just that in and of itself I
thought was was kind of refreshing yeah
it has the unintended consequence that I
often frame things before people wake up
so if there's something that happens say
in the afternoon the the pundits and
people
and understand to deal with it and
sometimes I'm the first person they hear
saying well the way to look at this is
this is important and this isn't and
somewhat accidentally I became
influential do you think that's sort of
your primary skill like a sort of
framing of the craziness and what we're
obviously going to get to the book in a
little bit but I think that's sort of
what you're doing is you're helping
people frame through just like this
endless onslaught of information so I
often say I have one superpower so I've
got one superpower and then a bunch of
like supporting talents that I've tried
to piece together over time superpowers
is simplification I'm just a really good
simplifier which is what makes one a
cartoonist cartoon is by its definition
the simplest thing you can put in this
little panel so if you can simplify you
can frame because it's taking down all
the noise focusing on the thing that
mattered so I naturally have the skill
as a simplifier yeah it's kind of funny
because that's almost the reverse of
what everyone else is doing and this
sort of is what the book is about like
everyone else is pretending they know
everything about everything all day long
you know people who can't tie their
shoes can tell you about climate change
and you know the rest of it so it's like
you're sort of doing the reverse of what
seemingly most of the bluejacket
Twitterati is up to you should ignore
anybody who has a sense of complete
certainty about a complicated issue you
know unless they're a surgeon and it's
their domain but if it's just guy on
twitter talking about climate change or
the I don't trade with China they don't
know how do you figure out who you kind
of can listen to or make some sense out
of or something like that I just help
everybody I find the only way to look at
all the windows is you've got it like
figure out what everybody's saying and
then maybe you've got a little bit of a
ability to determine which one is more
sensible if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell